[Música]
soy cirujano
desde siempre los cirujanos
pensamos que para tener más trabajo
tenemos que buscar más motivos para
operar más pacientes
en mis últimos diez años
mi investigación en mi caso en el
esófago se basó en buscar los motivos
para operar cada vez menos a los
pacientes
eso se puede hacer de varias maneras lo
hacemos por ejemplo buscando genes para
detectar enfermedades más temprano como
el cáncer y así no tener que operar las
podemos ayudar a los tejidos a repararse
por sí solos utilizando su propia
capacidad de regenerarse esto lo hacemos
con los andamios biológicos que son como
mapas que le damos al tejido para que
utilice su propia capacidad de
restaurarse después de un daño
y finalmente con las nuevas tecnologías
podemos por ejemplo con un endoscopio
hacer procedimientos y preservar órganos
donde antes había que operar y sacarlos
la robótica nos está dando un montón de
herramientas para facilitar estas tareas
lo que antes parecía ciencia ficción hoy
es casi cotidiano es alucinante
desafiar mis propios paradigmas de tener
cada vez más pacientes para operar me
dio muchas satisfacciones a mí y a un
montón de pacientes que evitaron tener
que hacerse una cirugía
con todo esto que les conté me di cuenta
que desarrollando métodos cada vez menos
invasivos tengo cada vez más trabajo
[Aplausos]
[Música]